um so to all of you Barbie has had many
jobs as a represented in our audience
today I'm lawyer doctor everything so
what were all of your first paid jobs
oh also I'm going to start with the Sigh
okay
I was saying um I was a little League
umpire
oh
should have checked the rules before
doing that gig because man who those
parents on this side and on this side
what what and I'm like I don't was it a
ball was it a strike what is the
difference and
and can she be running now I don't know
um she's out
is she out I don't know uh sorry I'm
gonna just let anybody
[Laughter]
no I I think I said I knew the room and
I I did on some level they were there
somewhere and um it didn't go so that's
like fired you were fired from my um
well that's shocking
find someone that knows you were an
actor before you're an actor you know
how actors are always lying on your
resume I can totally ride a horse I'm
Jolene equestrian I'm totally this you
were just ahead of your game um America
what about you what was your first paid
job the first job I got paid to do that
wasn't like an official job was my next
door neighbor had a very big pop belly
pig
and I got paid to clean up after the
pick yeah that's what I did all right
yeah making money at a young age I like
it I was a hustler you know I would take
it where I could get it absolutely what
about you Isa um similar I had a
neighbor who
um needed her cat's babysat that rhymes
um and I did that at like eight but then
I discovered that I was allergic so I
had to quit the next day
I found out I was allergic the hard way
too I rescued one and I was like what is
happening I just couldn't get it
together and you're like we were highly
allergic to cats was like super episode
I found her a home me too I love cats I
can't mess with them no more than dogs
because I'm right um but anyway
I'm just kidding but not
um so what about you what was like your
first paid job I had I started as a
hustler too I started young I was
working in a restaurant when I started
when I was 10 working in like the back
in the kitchen but um my hustle started
earlier than that I used to actually my
way of making money before I was working
at a restaurant
um I would steal my brother's toys and
then sell them out on the street
I know and he'd get so mad where's my
truck feeling and I was like I got two
bucks for it
can I have some of the money I was like
nope
that wasn't your store out on the street
that was my store
[Music]
[Applause]